now to another big story we're following
the supreme court delivering a seismic
victory for gun owners and the second
amendment liberal leaders going
ballistic over a ruling that is set to
rock blue states from coast to coast the
nation's highest court tossing out new
york state's restrictive regulations on
concealed carry permits and saying
americans have a legal right to carry
firearms in public for self-defense
it basically means millions of people
will no longer have to jump through so
many hoops if they want to protect
themselves and the bombshell ruling
could spread to other blue states like
california the white house and new york
leaders furious and lashing out
today the supreme court is sending us
backwards in our efforts to protect
families and prevent gun violence
shocking
absolutely shocking i'm sorry this dark
day has come this decision has made
every
single
one of us less safe from gun violence
and we cannot allow new york to become
the wild wild west we the president
myself many of us are deeply
concerned and troubled by the supreme
court's ruling today
um it it i believe defies common sense
and um the constitution the fact that
the court is coming down with this
decision feels tone on death and i i
worry that it undermines the legitimacy
of the court i am disappointed in the
supreme court gun decision i think it's
a bad decision i think it's
and i think it's
not reasoned accurately but i'm
disappointed
and the ladies of the view are taking
their outrage to a whole new level
i don't even have the words it seems
stupid
no it's worse than that it's worse than
that it's not even stupid it is it's
it's
no it's it's so it's such a middle
finger to new york
judge what do you think the chances are
that whoopi goldberg actually read any
of the opinions
you know what i'd probably wager uh my
house on that one i really would i gotta
tell you this decision by the united
states supreme court is a full throated
defense of the second amendment and the
supreme court is basically saying
this is a constitutional second
amendment that is explicit for all of
those who are concerned about roe and
they're trying to work it in implicit
and kind of it's drawn in and
interpreted this is explicit where they
basically say you new york state you
cannot add additional requirements if
someone wants a handgun or a revolver
they come and they get permission for
that
you give them that permission you cannot
then say to them by the way if you want
to carry this gun then you're going to
have to show a special need and the
special need to them is some
circumstance where you in particular are
are subjected to some kind of of of of a
crime or offense and the supreme court
said no there is no second test there is
only the first test 43 states require
you to get a license to carry a gun and
they said that's fine but you don't go
to level two and say and now if you want
to carry it you've got to prove that x y
and z and the two guys who brought this
uh uh uh uh
appeal were guys who were experienced in
carrying guns and using guns one lived
in a neighborhood where there were a lot
of robberies and the supreme court came
down and i gotta tell you justice thomas
was like it wasn't having any of it he
says there is nothing in the second
amendment that draws a home public
distinction with respect to the right to
bear arms and what what i think is
incredible is in terms of new york
they're saying uh and this is a quote
from the decision the respondents
attempt to characterize new york's
proper cause requirement that means you
have to show more reason to have a gun
as a sensitive place lacks total merit
because there is no historical basis for
new york to effectively declare the
island of manhattan a sensitive place
simply because it's crowded and
protected generally by the new york city
police department so that's the answer
to mayor eric adams who's so outraged i
want to know why all these liberals are
not outraged by the criminals carrying
the illegal guns and don't tell me that
they are because they're not they're
letting them out of jail to hit the
streets again and victimize the rest of
us and i want to read one more quote
from this decision they say in in that
that there is in the united states an
enduring american tradition that permits
a public carry so don't even question it
yeah judge makes the point that you
don't really hear kamala harris or other
democrats talk a lot about inner city
shootings they really don't ever talk
about it until today now they're
extremely concerned about it dana and
she said that um it doesn't pass the
common sense test and then she added or
the constitution but actually
you just had six justices say that it
does and and
i think the other thing that's happening
is that people who didn't read the
opinion and gave hot takes and there
were so many hot takes it was like 150
degrees outside today there were so many
um they they weren't looking at what the
narrow question was of this it didn't
say that everybody
now all of a sudden you're going to be
handed getting a handgun like you were
covid tess that's not happening it was
it was very specific it was very narrow
and i'll tell you the gun control
advocates they should never have pursued
this because and that was for from years
ago i remember learning that that they
could lose in this case
it takes a long time to get to the
supreme court um and now you have this
but i couldn't believe mayor adams said
that we won't have any sleep
why are they so afraid of law abiding
people these are people who've already
as the judge just laid out you passed
the background check you passed the test
in order to have your own weapon the
only thing is are you allowed to take it
with you that's the only question that
though they are law-abiding people and
um there will be a lot more to say on
this or some great uh commentary i would
if you want to read something that will
help you really understand it charles
cook over at national review has a great
piece a lot of people greg don't
understand how difficult it is to get a
handgun here in new york city i am i
have to say i mean i've got gone through
going through the process and it's it's
it was a pain in the neck it still is
but a lot of it had to do with the the
covid stuff everything kind of shut down
so it's not entirely just the red tape
but i had to jump through a lot of hoops
uh
you know when mayor adams says it's
going to be a wild wild west i can't
imagine it getting worse than it is now
right i mean it's like we got you know
it's
what you said it's like they're not that
upset about the law breakers they're
more worried about the law-abiding
people and i'm trying i think about mass
shooters
i don't believe and
someone can correct me later uh i won't
listen
i don't believe anybody with a concealed
carry permit ever committed a mass
shooting uh and so i think the ban
itself
had no role
in in like preventing these things right
but you could argue that a concealed
carry or a of that could help stop a
mass shooting because it creates uh it
creates uncertainty among the suspects
it's why the aurora shooter skipped a
few movie theaters because he knew that
there were guns there
and also we know that just the science
of it the the the
number of people dying in a mass
shooting is totally dependent on the
time it takes for a gun to get there
right and given the fact that at the
last shooting in texas
that the police had the guns and didn't
do it
and boy does that argue for this because
if there had been a person because and
and this is not to condemn the police
but because there's the fog of war
aspect going on but in this fog of war
there might be somebody within that war
in that room that might have stopped it
as opposed to the people out there and
then the last word just on hochel is
that her name i always call her she's a
yokel she thinks she's a [ __ ] she's as
sharp as a frisbee
she's done nothing
nothing to curb this epidemic of crime
in this state
so she has no right to come and complain
when the public embraces self-protection
as a right the fact is you you know you
let out
you let out repeat
offenders you defund you reduce
penalties for gun crime uh forgive me if
i'm going to turn my house into an armed
fortress
you're here a differ slightly
so let me say this i i think the the
court uh a 6-3 decision i remind you
judge you know as well roe v wade's a
7-2 decision so the numbers around the
around the majority are relevant but
we're going to talk about we should talk
about all of it
two i asked myself a fundamental
question judge now and you you presided
and you prosecuted people and i would
ask everyone around the table because
we've talked about crime does
you feel safer
today knowing
uh that
people will be able to take their guns
outside their homes people who we hope
are saying i hope everyone who is is out
just trying to protect him or herself
but i tell say i'm not sure i feel safer
and i would pose the question to the
table too
i wonder where police officers and law
enforcement are going to come down on
this
i'm not when i was in congress law
enforcement organizations
didn't mind common sense restrictions
because they were concerned about
criminals and others and understand
someone who's not a criminal today who
takes a gun and uses it for criminal
purposes becomes a criminal uh right
after that so i hear all of the
excitement and i again i'm not i'm not
here to to pour water but i am here to
just just offer
a couple questions
whatever we think about atoms and
whatever we think about the police chief
and whatever you think about hulkel i
believe they're trying to make the city
safer are they doing everything they
should judge i would agree you and i
would agree on this they're not they're
things more things they should be doing
but just because we don't like some of
the things they're not doing on two and
three other steps doesn't mean that we
should gleefully say that this is the
right thing for the city i hope i'm
wrong and if i'm wrong i'll be the first
to say god dawg we should have been we
should have armed everybody in the city
five years ago 10 years ago 15 years ago
when i moved here but i'm just not
convinced that that's where we're going
we're going to end up and again i hope
i'm wrong the answer to your first
question is
the question being do i feel safer
that's not the test right this is what i
actually would say i just ask if you
felt we talk a lot on this set about
issues and issues that impact the issue
so i'm just asking one of the reasons
that uh just i read with the justice
thomas he talked about what should be
one of the plaintiffs said like i want
to carry this gun i live in a
neighborhood i have a neighborhood where
there's some crime going so this guy
wanted to protect himself and the
question i ask again based on that you
know because that's that's an important
element to this case is do we feel safer
and again i don't know the end right now
i don't and i hope i hope i'm i hope i'm
proven wrong and if i'm proven wrong
i'll come right back around this table
and say you guys you were exactly right
but it's not a popularity contest when
something is guaranteed by the
constitution
you see it's not whether or not we agree
and hello you know scalia didn't say and
hillary said didn't say it was absolute
and even the concurring opinions but mr
decision
they support heller and mcdonald and i
don't want to get into the into the
uh something happened in this show for
the first time in the history of all
cable television
you had a panelist saying i don't know
the answer so you have to give points
for harold for saying that because you
never hear that
arguments that you're
reading today from people who are upset
about this decision
just watch until the dobbs decision is
announced and they will be making the
exact opposite case to try to make their
case there and that won't make sense ooh
all right
that is not an explicit right exactly
precisely hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else